- [Voiceover] Where is the
point on the number line?
Here we have a number
line that starts at 1.5
or 1 5/10 and goes to 1 7/10.
The distance between these
larger blue tick marks
is 1/10 because we go
from 1 5/10 to 1 6/10,
so that went up at 1/10
and then up to 1 7/10.
This distance here is 1/10
or we could write that as
0.1 or as a fraction 1/10.
That distance between each of these
blue large tick marks is 1/10,
but we want to know what is
this green point right here.
To figure that out we also
need to figure out what do
these black tick marks represent,
these smaller distances.
From here to here is 1/10,
and within that 1/10th
there are one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10 equal spaces.
Each of these little spaces
is 1/10 of this distance
because it's one of the 10 equal spaces.
This, right here, is 1/10th of this 1/10th
because the large distance is 1/10th
and this is 1/10 of that 1/10th.
Another way we could say that is 1/100.
1/10th of 1/10th, if you
take 1/10 and divide it
into 10 pieces, now you have 1/100.
This distance is 1/100 which
means that each of these
distances, this is another
1/100 and another 1/100,
so how many 1/100 till
we get to our point?
Let's see.
1/100, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
7/100 is what it took us to get there,
so we could say 7/100, the
fraction or the decimal, 0.07
with a seven in the hundreds place.
Looking at the whole number
line now, putting the whole
thing together, we
started at 1.5 or 1 5/10,
and we went another 7/100, so
we can write that as +7/100.
We have 1 5/10 plus 7/100
which is a total of 1 57/100 or 1.57.
Our point, right here, is at 1.57.
1 5/10 plus 7/100 gets us to 1 57/100.